Oh
occupy la began on october first at City
Hall in downtown Los Angeles shortly
after the largely dismissed mostly
misinterpreted orphaned child of the
Occupy movement became one of the
largest and longest standing us
occupations hi I'm Tim Cavanaugh a
reason TV we're here with Sam Slovak a
journalist who has also made a series of
movies about occupy la Sam thank you for
joining us you want to tell us a little
bit about what we can look for and where
we can find your work right thanks for
having me occupy la scenes from the new
revolution is the name of the series and
it's a five-part series that i did with
take part which is the online arm of
participant media my intention really
was as soon as i started found out about
occupy lay i'm a journalist in los
angeles so if I'm not covering that what
am i doing I'm not covering the second
American Revolution so my intention was
to get down there do what I do best and
that is to find the people and meet the
people and hear their story and tell
their story what was the difference
between occupy la and occupy wall street
which even today is still the one that
the everybody refers to occupy la was at
city hall in los angeles downtown two
blocks from Skid Row they were they had
a policy of inclusion of all inclusion
so what immediately happened was there
was an incursion of people from Skid Row
which includes parolees people right out
of County Jail people with mental health
issues people with addiction issues all
the issues you could pick any one of
them and trace the tracks of it back to
the larger issue of the movement
reportedly the police were telling
people who got out of County Jail go
over there there's free food at City
Hall you could probably get a tent so
you had all these people camped on the
front of City Hall in the middle of that
was a very high functioning expeditious
group of activists can you explain a
little bit about the General Assembly a
way of into the block and all that kind
of stuff it's all everybody it's a
it all seems like nostalgia at this
point it struck me as I would not want
to have to live under this kind of
organization it better just a bunch of
political hacks that you only have to
worry about voting for them every two
years or four years in some sense is
what's going on on the South steps of
City Hall is the same thing that's going
on in City Hall hopefully the exception
that they're not immoral like our
politicians are does that interest you i
mean it seemed to me really dull it
seemed like then this is a completely
process-oriented rather than you know
product oriented and just it was
everything i don't like about government
like everybody else i showed up with a
lot of judgment i showed up and kind of
rolled my eyes and thought maybe i
should walk across the street to the
Conrad Murray trial at least I can you
know get a story or something the more I
started to watch the ga the more I
realized that these people are going to
change our country they already have
they already are you're having
conversations with your children about
you know economics and corrupt
government that probably wouldn't have
happened everybody is people are talking
about this the conversation has begun
the process initially when i sat in on
GA s was challenging because there's a
lot of challenging personalities there's
a lot of people who want to be heard
who've never had their voice heard
before and there's chaos because we're
in la by skidrow but the more i watched
and the longer i watched the more i was
fascinated completely engaged and wanted
it to go on longer what do you think of
the media coverage and specifically what
do you think of the difference between
the media coverage of the Tea Party
movement of 2010 and the Occupy movement
of 2011 the Tea Party was playing ball
with the media they're in the game
they're an aspect of the Republican
Party right there in the game they're
doing the dance occupy something very
different and we haven't seen it before
and that's what's so incredibly powerful
and you know potentially explosive so
why is it that the Tea Party was
dismissed in the New York Times as a
racist organization by Robert Putnam and
the New York Times actually had a
rapport
embedded with the Occupy movement who
was in fact arrested on the Brooklyn
Bridge right so I sounds to me like it's
the actually it's the Occupy movement
this playing ball I wouldn't say either
one of them were playing ball but I
would say the media was much friendlier
in its coverage of the Occupy movement
than it was of the Tea Party move but of
course the new york times you know why
wouldn't they be i mean in favor of
Occupy Wall Street of course that it
seems like that's the establishment
media and you're claiming that the
occupant of the Occupy movement was
anti-establishment but yeah it's a do
you view the New York Times as a
conservative newspaper I view it as the
establishment newspaper right the left
aspect of the establishment yeah I'm
possibly yeah I you know I think
generally the Republicans of Democrats
agree more than they disagree well
because they're all in the same game
it's one party corporate America what's
the difference between a protest and an
occupation there were protests the
Occupy movement that came out of the
occupation the nine ten percent
movements occupation in Los Angeles
there were protests right but the
occupation itself you know the
occupation is the hub the City Council
voted a resolution in support of occupy
la and everybody i spoke with and we we
interviewed many many many people at
these this move at the event said we are
here until there is a former until there
is a solution less than a month after
the city council passes this resolution
it sends the police in to break up the
movement did they not have any kind of
duty of honor to to let you guys stay as
long as you want it to you mean to let
the occupation remain on this public
property and I mean down tablet we maybe
we should explain for the Earth's
downtown LA is is mostly or you know and
maybe almost fifty percent prairie land
I mean there's there's a ton of publicly
owned empty city blocks in downtown LA
where the the
movement could have been accommodated
and in fact why not just do it at City
Hall why not allow people to stay at
City Hall the reporter potties there and
that's this since the the plumbing is
what the media are always interested in
at events I mean they were taking care
of themselves so why not why did they
have to be moved out it was at a news
conference with the mayor one of his
closed-door news conferences that I shot
right before he announced he made the
announcement about the eviction the
rumor that I've heard is that he was of
course getting a lot of pressure you
know this looks bad you gotta get these
people out of here and second of all
that he personally was offended and
wanted the this occupation gone in the
beginning he came down with rain ponchos
you know it's a tactic these were just
tactics of course um so that's that's
what I heard I heard it was coming that
he was essentially driving it and then
he was getting a lot of pressure and he
wanted this occupation gone the general
consensus story was that the eviction
went relatively well there was no nobody
died and so for that yeah well I'm not
sure if you heard the whole story
because i was actually interviewing a
woman named Elise Whitaker who is at the
core of this whole thing is 21 year old
activist yesterday she said they put her
in jail for three days the 14 hours of
it was and they put her in solitary
confinement and you're saying it went
have they there was a woman on the bus
that kept people in buses 48 hours was
85 years old out to urinate in a plastic
bags they wouldn't let him use about him
so the you're saying well went pretty
well well I guess in terms of what I
didn't say and I didn't say it in that
namby-pamby mimicking voice that you
just used our producer Paul was there
for the eviction and you know it went
quickly it was over by the end of the
day none of the abuses that you're
talking about ended up getting media
play so I what I'm saying is that the
narrative that you laid out that the
LAPD was looking to be the spiffy new
officer friendly that keeps the peace
they succeeded in passing that story
along they did a fantastic job as a
extreme show of force and arrested 300
people who were expressing their First
Amendment rights on public property so
in that sense it was a tremendous
success people say what did these people
want where's the list of demands you
know and it's like it's an embryonic
movement the primordial ooze just
bubbled up and you can't throw a cran
into da Vinci's baby crib and tell them
to paint the Mona Lisa it's not there
yet but you're going to be finding out
for sure we're all going to be finding
out terrific well thank you very much
Sam Slovak for recent event in capital